Замість Донецька - Кривий Ріг.
Замість 15 приміщень з обладнанням загальною вартістю
у понад три мільйони євро - одне приміщення колишньої школи.
Донецький юридичний інститут - головний виш Донбасу з підготовки юристів та поліцейських
за 2 роки після евакуації зміг відновити свою роботу.
Стільці і парти є, викладацький стіл
Навіть не в усіх аудиторіях є дошка для крейди,
але вона є. І інститут помаленьку з цим справляться
Три роки тому в цьому приміщенні було сміття,
яке самі ж курсанти з викладачами і прибрали.
З більш-менш прийнятним спецобладнанням їмдопомогло
МВС  і колеги з сусідніх регіонів.
Сподіваємося, що з вересня запрацюємо в новому стрілецькому тирі.
А поки - лазерний тренажер.
Після евакуації МВС виділило вишу 3 мільйони гривень на те,
щоб розпочати діяльність "з нуля".
Цього вистачило на ремонт половини будівлі
і на часткове облаштування казарм.
Аліна з Сєвєродонецька мріяла навчатися в Донецькому юридичному інституті
ще зі школи. Тож те, яким він став, її не злякало.
Я бачу, в нас йдуть ремонті роботи,
буде відновлена наша казарма.
Я буду залишатися жити на другий рік.
Ця частина будівлі призначена саме для навчання поліцейських.
Зараз її капітально ремонтують.
Вартість реконструкції - близько мільйона євро.
Фінансує проектуряд Німеччини. З 2015 року
німці допомагаютьУкраїніподолати наслідки війни на Донбасі
і знизити соціальне навантаження на прифронтові
Харківську, Запорізькута Дніпропетровську області,
куди переїхали майже 350тисяч переселенців.
На німецькі кошти відновлять близько 80 дитсадків,
шкіл, лікарень , інших соціальних закладів,
реконструкцію яких місцева влада навряд чи  змогла б профінансувати.
Ми перевіряємо, чи довгостроковий проект,
як довго ним будуть користуватися, чи зможе місто його утримувати,
чи потрібен він взагалі,
чи покращує він ситуацію для переселенців
і для місцевих жителів.
Інженерка Бербель Швайґер
часто буває у відрядженнях у прифронтових областях.
Завдання у команди Німецького товариства міжнародної співпраці - непросте.
Адже вони мають домогтися від українських будівельників німецької якості.
Вже таке було, що вікна заново переставляли,
а також унітази, які були встановлені не на тій висоті.
Ми все дуже ретельно контролюємо.
Корпус для навчання поліцейських Донецького юридичного інститут в Кривому розі
німці планують завершити наступного літа.
Керівництво впевнено, жодних затримок не буде.
І тоді інститут зможе прийняти вже 400, а може й 800 курсантів та студентів.